[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction voici
lé titre de ce 7 mars 2017
le parc de thoiry victimes de
braconniers la nuit dernière un
rhinocéros a été découverte est tué par
balle une de ses cornes sectionné un
événement inédit dans un parc européen à
la région s'interroge sur le financement
des transports et c'est le pass navigo
qui pourraient être augmentés une table
ronde vient de se tenir
le point sur les premières conclusions
et puis chaque mardi nous vous proposons
de découvrir un yvelinois rencontre
aujourd'hui avec sébastien serveau il
propose ses services en tant que
consultant en pâtisserie c'est une
première une triste première dans un zoo
européen un rhinocéros du parc de thoiry
a été découvert tué par balles ce matin
une de ses cornes sectionné à l'animal
âgé de 5 ans présente plusieurs impacts
à la tête l'une de ses défenses a été
découpé à la tronçonneuse
les gendarmes de la brigade de
recherches de mantes-la-jolie sont en
charge de l'enquêté
les salariés sont sous le choc le parc a
toujours été mobilisés contre ce trafic
il avait organisé une grande conférence
sur ce thème en 2013
le braconnage qui occupe la quatrième
place dans le classement mondial des
marchés criminels derrière la drogue la
cybercriminalité ou encore à la traite
des êtres humains
une corne de rhinocéros se monnaye
jusqu'à 40000 euros
c'est très très très choquant parce que
là tout tous nos confrères et tous sont
terriblement choqué que c'est pu arriver
dans un parc zoologique
on part quand même du principe que les
animaux qui sont dans un parc zoologique
son protégé justement du braconnage
qu'on rencontre dans la nature donc là
c'est très très choquant dans
l'actualité également l'europe et cette
ambition de relancer l'union européenne
à quelques semaines seulement du 60e
anniversaire du traité de rome à
l'invitation de françois hollande
plusieurs chefs d'état se sont réunis à
versailles
hier les dirigeants espagnols italiens
allemands pour se
mini sommet depuis la dernière demeure
des rois de france le chef de l'état a
appelé à une union forte mais à
plusieurs vitesses que certains états
puissent rapidement parvenir à
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale ou
encore renforcer leur collaboration en
matière de défense
l'unité n'est pas l'uniformité at il
également martelé
si nous voulons que l'europe soit au
rendez vous pour les prochaines années
elle doit d'abord tirer les conséquences
du break site et être capable de vivre à
27 est qu'à 27 nous puissions être
suffisamment uni pour être respecté
c'est une problématique essentielle pour
le développement de la région
ile-de-france comment financer les
futurs investissements dans les
transports en commun experts et
politiques se sont réunis c'était ce
matin à paris à l'initiative du syndicat
des transports en ile de france ils ont
discuté de cette thématique un enjeu
majeur alors que les sources de
financements se tarissent quand les
investissements eux doivent augmenter en
toile de fond pour les usagers c'est à
une augmentation du passe navigo et qui
se profilent les précisions sont signées
nicolas quere lovitz des trains plus
efficace des rames plus moderne à une
sécurité renforcée les ambitions portées
par le stif et la région ile-de-france
sont élevées pour les transports en
commun franciliens
mais alors comment les financer d'ici
2030 plus de 20 milliards d'euros
d'investissements sont prévus nouveau
matériel roulant nouvelles lignes comme
le tram 13 dans les yvelines ou encore
le grand paris express
il faut donc trouver des ressources
supplémentaires qui pourraient déboucher
sur une nouvelle hausse de la
tarification pour les voyageurs ça fait
quinze ans que chaque année en moyenne à
2 5%
le pass navigo ou la carte orange
augmente donc c'est pas un sujet nouveau
et oui il continuera naturellement
d'augmenter la présidente s'est engagé à
ce qu'il n'augmente ce qui est pas ce
qui était un changement avec ce qui se
passait avant est-ce qu'il n'augmente
qu'avec de l'offre supplémentaire cette
année il a augmenté enfin la dernière il
a augmenté de 3 euros nous à bruz de
l'offre supplémentaire
en contrepartie ces salles engagement
politique qui est pris par la présidente
autre solution envisagée pour disposer
de nouvelles recettes des tarifs plus
élevés pour les touristes l'instauration
de recreuser heure pleine ou encore la
mise à contribution des automobilistes
vient à péage urbain à l'instar du
modèle britannique
on oublie de dire que sur les millions
de déplacements quotidiens en
ile-de-france pratiquement 60% se font
aujourd'hui en automobile donc il faut
prendre au sérieux l'automobile peut
être investir sur la voirie dans
certaines zones et symétriquement
demande et assurer les mobistes de
contribuer d'autant que ces
contributions du type péage de
congestion ou péage en périodes de
pollution
c'est aussi un moyen de rendre la
mobilité plus durable un londonien peut
débourser jusqu'à 415 euros par mois
pour ses déplacements transports en
commun contre 73 euros jusqu'à présent
avec le pass navigo pour un parisien
et puisque nous parlions de la région
sachez que dans le cadre de la journée
internationale du droit des femmes ce 8
mars la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes devient une grande
cause en ile-de-france pour 2017
l'annoncé a été faite aujourd'hui par
valérie pécresse
nous reviendrons sur cette journée sur
les opérations organisées également dans
les yvelines dans notre prochaine
édition de demain mercredi à partir de
18 heures les maison d'enfants à
caractère social ont peur pour leur
avenir ces centres d'hébergement voici
les images pour jeunes en difficulté
plus communément appelée foyer dénonce
des restrictions budgétaires au niveau
des départements qui les financent un
mouvement de grève a été lancé au niveau
national
le foyer l'étape à montigny le
bretonneux a opté pour un débrayage à
d'un peu moins d'une heure c'était en
début d'après midi
une pétition sera transmise au conseil
départemental des yvelines
à ce jour il ya des restrictions
budgétaires qu'il faut qu' il va y avoir
de moins en moins de
d'argent de financement pour les maisons
d'enfants à caractère social et elles
vont être en voie de disparition avec
une diminution de jeunes une diminution
de déplacement les maisons d'enfants
n'auront pu de de budget de financement
dans les yvelines ce sont les petites
associations qui sont visés et nous
avons deux associations de petites qui
ont déjà fermé santé maintenant avec le
sujet de la dépendance du maintien à
domicile des seniors des entreprises
sont engagées sur ce marché et c'est le
cas d'une société élan courtoise blue
line et à la développer un nouveau
projet d'ehpad à domicile établissement
public la dedd pour ces personnes
seniors le reportage est signée patrick
jacques de dixmude et nicolas landry
prolonger l'espérance de vie des seniors
c'est l'objectif de l'entreprise blue
line et à elle propose des objets
connectés comme ce bracelet gps pour
accompagner les personnes âgées au
quotidien pourquoi aujourd'hui à des
gens qui vieillissent mieux que d'autres
alors c'est intéressant de suivre leur
activité de suivre leur présence et ça
suffit pas il faut aussi s'intéresser à
leur état psychologique donc douter les
suivront des personnes sur les actes et
sur les aspects psycho social et ainsi
nous arrivons à contribuer à ce que des
personnes âgées vieillissent mieux à
leur domicile bien évidemment
l'entreprise propose aussi des
détecteurs de chute effet des suivis du
poids et de la température des données
directement envoyées à la plateforme de
blue line et à des dispositifs déployés
dans toute la france et plus récemment
en allemagne
en quatre ans nous avons vécu 9 100 % de
croissance de notre chiffre d'affaires
on est passé de 6 collaborateurs à une
petite centaine et nous avons nous
sommes passés de zéro client particulier
après dix sept mille alors chez nous la
dépendance ça n'existe pas la perte
d'autonomie ça n'existe pas nous on
parle de réussir à prolonger l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé des seniors
92% des personnes âgées de plus de 75
ans restent à leur domicile près de 1,3
millions de seniors sont dans une
situation de dépendance
[Musique]
à nous passons portrait de la semaine
iny montain depuis 16 ans sébastien
serveau et pâtissiers chocolatiers en
2005 et il est devenu membre du très
sélect club des sucres est présidé par
le champion du monde de pâtisserie et
christophe michalak ne cherchez pas de
boutiques à son nom la plus grande
partie de son travail consiste en du
consulting en france ou à l'étranger ils
se déplacent au gré des demandes mélanie
de poker
il commence toujours par un dessin des
traits de crayon et la pièce prend forme
sébastien serveau n'est pas dessinateurs
et les pâtissiers chocolatiers gelé dans
la tête mais entre ce qu'on a dans la
tête et ce qui va être réalisable c'est
pas toujours facile donc j'ai besoin de
me poser d'être sûr sur un dessin avant
de pouvoir me lancer à la transformation
avec le chocolat en fait ça dépend ce
qu'on me demande des fois ça peut être
un par exemple un d'entre eux mais où il
ya plein de textures à l'intérieur donc
moi dans ma tête déjà j'aimais les idées
donc il faut juste que je le mette sur
un papier pour après me rendre compte un
petit peu de ce que ça va donner mais en
l'occurrence le dessin me mettre
vraiment à m'asseoir sur quelque chose
et a pas appris à partir plus facilement
sur mes essais alors là c'est une petite
quantité parce que j'ai qu'un seul qu'un
seul bateau à faire mais après quand on
travaille en séries on travaille avec
une poche
diplômé il y à plus de 25 ans il
s'oriente très vite vers la pâtisserie
de grandes adresses françaises pendant
20 ans puis à son compte
ce jour là sébastien met la touche
finale à un modèle autour de pâques
pendant deux jours il sera dans le gers
dans un lycée professionnel rouge
énormément en france mais surtout à
l'étranger
la semaine prochaine je suis au maroc
après j'enchaîne avec la chine
j'ai fait donc les etats-unis le japon
le mexique fin voilà beaucoup de
beaucoup de pays sont demandeurs de la
pâtisserie la gastronomie française le
consulting en fait c'est un client qui
qui me sollicitent pour me demande bien
particulière ça peut être une création
de cartes pour un restaurant ça peut
être un renouvellement de carte aussi ça
peut être un établissement qui va ouvrir
et qui veut recruter son personnel qui
veut former son personnel manager aussi
donc ça c'est mon rôle je suis pas que
de la création que la pâtisserie je suis
aussi le management
autre facette de son activité depuis
trois ans chaque mois il distille ses
conseils dans le journal du pâtissier un
magazine professionnel avec le
photographe thierry caron on a eu
beaucoup de retours positifs de la part
des électeurs
donc il ya eu un sondage de fait et
notamment les professionnels que je
rencontre sur les salons ou quand je
fais des formations quand je me déplace
à l'étranger également donc des retours
très positifs donc c'est très
intéressant
de voir que les recettes que je peux
mettre dans le magazine sont lus mais
sont aussi exécuté sébastien serveau est
aussi l'auteur d'une dizaine de livres
de pâtisserie de quoi vous mettre l'eau
à la bouche
et pour terminer ce jour là nous parlons
culture à présent dans le cadre du
projet éducatif génération lully les
habitants de trappes était invitée la
semaine dernière à découvrir le
spectacle at his en folie une création
du centre de musique baroque de
versailles je vais pour la première fois
en france c'est une parodie du célèbre
compositeur jean baptiste lully chant
musique marionnettes la comédie le
spectacle fait appel à de nombreuses
compétences tout ça pour un même
objectif faire rire
on écoute le metteur en scène et il
était au micro de canal
ces pièces là on peut vraiment dire que
ce sont les ancêtres de la comédie
musicale alternance du parler et dû
chanter donc il faut savoir vraiment
bien joué et naturellement enchantées
parce que c'est du niveau de l'opéra le
public est réceptif
aujourd'hui au même chose qu'au xviie
siècle sur tous les degrés de l'humour
et a énormément d'humour grivois dans
ses parodies mais aussi un humour qui
fait allusion à toute la culture de
l'époque et à tout l'environnement
théâtrale c'est la fin de ce journal les
programmes se poursuivre sur notre
antenne ils sont aussi à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile très belle soirée sur tv fils
[Musique]